Oh. Oh.
Well, ugly morning, sunny for the good-w coups.
Oh.
Yeah, fuck those. I'm making it.
Yeah, I live in the parking lot, you know what I'm saying.
Maybe it's just getting the content.
Nope.
Oh. A bird outside my window!
Well...
Are you squidding me right now?
Good morning, good evening. Good afternoon. Let me make myself be because one of them games wrong. Oh
Not too big though. I'm just
What's going on with my spout
Spout I'm good. No, no, I'm tiny. What spout? No, no, I'm off the screen spout
You wind me up
The
Successfully been warned. Oh, hold on. I think Calvary
Hold on Calvary
Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. Um, it's pig. It's time for a pig one
It's time for a pig one. Thank you mix the couple for the membership back to
Back to
What's that there was no ASMR video and no patreon update
Yeah, maybe
Oops, like I'm working on it tomorrow
I've finally finished handing off everything needed for the video game and I've come to the absolute terrible
Realization and bulls to up beyond belief but like hey, oh it is what it is
It's the first time I've ever taken on a project of that size and oh
Boy, have I learned from my mistakes? Oh, turns out I'm an idiot. Oh dear
I could have done a lot better, but that's the best I can do
With a little brainstem and the brain cells I had at the time
Then my brain is expanded. So if I ever do something like that again, at least I want horrifically butchered and
You're gonna load 2,000 hours into this one. I'm on my Harry plan won't go
Oh
Remember that time that gentleman's wife died at our restaurants, but because he signed up for
Disney Plus
We know we said no to them. Oh my goodness
It's been a while all I'm saying is it's been a while
Did I sleep I did I took my drug I took my sleep medication
I was like fuck this. I can't be doing this to myself. Um
And I have terrible news for myself
For the next three days, I have to wake up at like a one o'clock in the morning
So I'm gonna have to drug off again
After today's stream, but what I need to do is try and stay awake and not nap
But I had six hours, which is really good for me. I had a nap and then I had six hours. That's good
But whatever I drug up. I always have a freaking loaf of bread that gets stuck in me and I'm like leave me alone
My little druggy, I can't believe I'm falling for the squash freaking issues of
being
Addicted to stuff like what are the odds on as if I missed that
I
Turn this down a bit hold on me turn that down. This is more of a most be honest. This is just a that's who
It's like Sarah's good, but you need more. Oh, I need more already. I sure yeah, I need more
No magic ham and being mean to me. Why are you bullying me if you don't want to know
Can I like get it stuck in here on purpose? No, don't bounce out. I wanted it to like get stuck
And but yes today is just like a boring
that's who
Tape game I said, oh wait, I'm supposed to go for the orange. Sorry
Sorry
Look, I said it's the first thing in the movie nice to me, but I had such an amazing time on black box yesterday
I was watching a bit of myself. I could not stop singing. I kept coming out with more and we remixes every two things
Oh
Just say you hate me
Um
Well fuck this one up right there. Yeah, it's not on my side. Okay. I thought I might be but
No, okay, well, we'll try that again
Yeah, we'll call it a spending time a moment or a new baby thing. Is it up?
She sent me the link but I don't think that's up moment. It's my birthday today. Oh, yeah, are you ready for this?
Happy birthday, bro, baby. Oh, yeah
Enjoy that and thank you for the super chat. I'm glad your birthday and now how old are you based on my statistics?
Did you get a famous? I absolutely did get a famous. I'll show you
No way that is perfectly going downwards. That's not even a thing in this game
That didn't hit the orange that's underneath
Just say you hate me
Why yeah, and then go for the art no
Don't do magic cat. It's not even gonna do anything
Oh, give me an extra ball in general, okay, that may help
Mns one eight. Thank you
Course I got family and I got the waffle stone for two
I
So on the Nova 6 level where you meet the scientists that stabilize that
Someone was like oh, there's an Easter egg in this level and you can get the
Thunder gun. I'm like what you on about. I've literally never heard this it took me like 15 minutes to grab it
Hey, thank you a moment. I'm 25. Oh my god
Welcome oji-san into the into the
Into the stream I'm Joe. I'm teasing you. I'm teasing you. Oh, please give me an extra ball. Oh, thank God. I
Everything's in the way. I'm not gonna get it. Oh
Well
Nice but nah, are you joking?
Retro
Give me the gosh darn
orange
Wait, don't go to it if I would you because I'm saying I don't know isn't would you sign a compliment or am I going mental?
Maybe it means a compliment in my head, but it's not
And now an expired Christmas cake walk
If you try it's only to a 24
I'm being so dumb. What does an expired Christmas cake mean again? Hold on a minute
Well, oh, she's coming. Oh, no, it's like saying old man, but isn't it good to be older as a man
Am I going mental
My brain isn't quite walking up yet. I've got a cup of tea in here
Oh
25 is would you sound 30 be flings and shambles? Well my statistics actually, you know fuck it
Let's just open up muscle to it pause the game. Oh pause the tunes. Come on. Let's go find out analytics audience
Subscribed and not subscribe not subscribe 45% wait, what's 45% of the number of subscribers I've got now
Would I be like that 30 key? Oh
My audience is 95% male 3.2% female 1.2 user and user specified. I don't know
The most common age range is actually 25 to 34 years on my youtube channel. So
Yeah
I don't wait. Hold on a minute. How can you guys tolerate all the shit that comes out of my mouth if you're older?
All I do is like just talk out my eyes
Are you tired of it?
Real thank you chair for this super chat your own your proposed work job me. I can't believe it
Hmm
Nice, I'm in the demographic. Yeah, I'm still just under there ain't there yet. Nothing happens when you turn 30
I'm like 100% sure nothing happened. What's the version of a male hag feature burger for it?
Did I tell you I said she was a hug in her application form?
I can't remember how she said that I'm sure she wouldn't make me turn this because it wasn't like anything bad
It was like in this section for like
Do you what do you want us to know about you?
I think she said something like I'll almost hag age, but don't let that put me
Put that off. Yeah. I'm like no. We're looking for you
I was so this is some insider knowledge. I had specifically been requested by the reeflings pre pre reeflings
Hey, we want to have each of our right and I was like your wish is my fucking command. I assure you and
Oh, did you get the serotonin?
So it was really funny that I was we're put it in our application form because I was like you're literally what I want
You're literally what I want like I think
I honestly couldn't have go if triple
Well, wait, no, I was giving these voices. What would a bunny sound like?
If triple scores is active, you only need around eight four hundred pinballs on a shot to get a free ball
That's a lucky spin for you. It pays and pays and pay. Are you telling me to gamble?
That was terrible. I need to like all these blues away so I can hit the orange
There a no
virgins in a wizard
Wizard wait is wizard a slang term?
Why would you don't want to be a wizard? It's a wizard and insult
You shall not
Interesting gaming we're talking about this is
Lake this stream if you're into Peggy Peggle, sorry
Oh
No, the meme okay, the meme is like some viral meme hardy-hard hard
And wizards wait no
Wizards means a
Virgin that's amazing. Oh
My god, hold on a minute. Let me cast some motherfucking spells on you
That's awesome. I like that power knowledge wizard. You're a wizard. Sorry
Two boys left. No, can he be but I've messed up this one as well
If you reach 30 without the touchable women you unlock powerful magic
That's so good. What's it?
What would the magic be?
The ability to focus on bros before hoes exactly you're welcome
You're welcome. It's like me learning about
What is it sharp ears or something like that?
Thank you. I was at nine years
There's your chance Johnny
Why do you think I say thank you for your cherry? They're no longer a wizard array
Me naming
Sharks don't have you mommy. You have to save the rooflings from getting magic
If it's bad magic sure fuck it
I grew up paying incision
Did you see what Amy tweeted out? I was absolutely he horn
Fucking saw the first sentence. I was like, I'm leaving viola. I'm like
Panic panic panic
And then obviously I read the rest of it and I was like panic over panic over. This is hilarious. I'm laughing
The I'm quitting yeah, if you didn't know any tweeted out I'm quitting viola and obviously I had just woken up like 20 minutes ago
So I don't have the ability to think and process things. I read properly. It's not just panic. Okay, did I think she was leaving I have I
Just think everyone wants to leave. I don't know. I just get scared. I'm like, I try so hard for like I
Just hope they think I'm doing enough and a
Oh shit, I forgot oh under the sea
All it together
Oh, I'm gonna win this one if I don't balls up. Oh
Oh
Extreme fever
Extreme fever hack too because I've got that people
How's it going strong? He's going great roofing. I'm gonna start slurping on my cup of tea
See, these are one of them streams where I can just fucking talk out my horse
I didn't have to think I didn't have to come up with anything over on the dragon
The awesome force of a fireball master Lord Cinder bottom
I
But what about the cool bunny? She be caught in thumb
I am large cinderbomb
Wait, I am large cinderbottom of the order of the flame and it is my privilege to prepare
Out to reveal to you the fireball fire cast of fake magic powers
The fireball burns to the balls and sparrows
If you've answered off the fear the free boy bucket, yes, I promise it will be
Your training begins
I'm not reading the rest of those words. That's gonna kill me
Straker green peggle. Well, I cannae because they're all hidden
Cinderbomb too much bean
Ah
I'm just trying to hit the green one. I cannae be that bad kind of right the green. Thank you a
Fireball next turn
We're about to see what this is
Mother
That was she well it was me cuz like I guess you can clear stuff. That's in your way to stuff
Okay, I was really lucky I was not paying attention to that watch too hot for you
hmm
Also, I've changed my schedule. You are in fact forced to be playing overwatch with me next week. No, I don't care
No, okay, I'm gonna play
I'm gonna play
Zarya that's who I used to play. I don't know if they absolutely butchered her or not, but
That's where I used to play Zarya. I'm gonna play Juno obviously because she's new and
Overwatch literally everyone taking mental HP and that's said damage in that stream
Okay, we ran out of balls. That's okay. We're gonna give it another shot
And and then we have a left-for-dead stream snipe coming up so I'll be interested to see how that goes
They can come in annoying
And but I know me. I mean I get to touch you in game. Oh, it was a fireball. I
Was the pain attention. Sorry. I'm too busy up and I
Can't wait, but I can so painful now
Like I'll be that if it's killing your refluence to tank for me so I can play healer. I will play the tank. It's okay
Nice left-for-ditch will be my first stream snip. Yeah, you can come and help me survive dad's on me. I know there's zombies
other than that
My knowledge is a bit limited in the game
So it'll be interesting to see she be did play left-for-dead on stream
with other
V-tubers. Yeah. Oh, no
Oh, come on. Hit. No. Hit something orange. Just say you hate me
Well, I've got fireball so
Who did I go for like through I think just these two down here
And it was far too late. I need to wake up. Well, let's drink this tea
Thank you, Broly legend as well for tanking for me wink wink
Me check I'll like hypnotize it. Oh, you want to tank for me so bad
Oh, you want to play will you do versus mode lobby?
I have never played the game, but if that's what you want, you can get what you want. Do you just have to tell me?
That's not gonna hurt
That's gonna scuffle side of that
Okay, I was like
Mercy it overwatch me by the way
Overwatch players are in the same category as league players
They hate themselves and everybody else and nobody else plays their main like they do
Be nice. I like a good cheeky bit of mercy
I like no having to think and just hold the beam and beam go brrrr. How dare you bro?
How dare you to be lords for insulting me? Okay? I like Zarya. I like mercy. I like Moira
I
Think I'm gonna like Juno cuz she can do the heel thing like Anna. I don't know if it's like oh
I think there's a healer called Larry
Oh
Wait, no, it's not Larry. It can't be L a r r y. There's no way it's Larry
I refuse. There's no way that there's a character called Larry in overwatch. I'm sorry. Please forgive me
I'm so sorry. Hey, I don't know. I don't know how our name is. Oh as if I just completely balls that one up
Yeah, oh
Okay, thank you video game this blue is in my way, so I'm just gonna get rid of it. Oh
The game is feeling rather nice today. What's going on?
You know Larry. Yeah, just like me for real
That Larry literally mean you're Larry at over what?
Winston how's it hanging? Oh good. Well, you know, oh, oh I get
Winston oh my god, we're zooming. Okay. Let me actually drink this tea. I've said that for like the last 20 seconds
Oh my god, it's right before it's lukewarm, so it's actually good
Mm-hmm
You begin to see the fearsome strength of the fireball. Do not let its power tempt you into the error of pride
The firm the flame serves only the virtuous. I don't know why it's turned into like an old lady
But go from
So what am I supposed to get the green
From here, I don't think it's gonna hit that's gonna be in the way
You're in the way you're in the way. Oh
Let's just go for the orange first then I'll see what to do about the shape don't do that again
Okay, okay, let me get up. Let me get up beautiful gorgeous
See who's Larry there's like a overwatch healer that begins with L. Oh
I should have waited for the damn thing. Sorry
Oh
Andres, thank you for the extended membership two months flies when you've been an awesome. Oh, thank you. I
Have four membership streams next week. I'm like night
99% sure I have four membership streams next week. Oh
Unless I've messed up I
Thought I had more
I
Larry, okay, so you know what I'm gonna say something controversial Larry wasn't wrong if her name is a larry
Larry was near on now. I'm no up as
if
As if my shitey aim cost. I just do that game
Mommy supports a larry. I know this cuz I'm stuck in the game. I can't quit you can't quit
Who's that? I knew it the overwatch brain rot has already got to us reeflings. We're like we're infected. You know when like those like
Species of animals are like they're they're going against like a parasitic thing
We're we've all been infected by overwatch at one point. I don't care why no one's in and before I never touch overwatch in my life
All right, then give me your virginity
Like I don't know what to tell you. Of course, we're jumping on overwatch
me
Right
Into this fireball
I got infected
by a leak of
All games. Do you hate yourself?
You know what in solidarity was there I should maybe play like once I
Don't know
I don't know if I can do it. Oh dies
You know, that's true love I love you so much
I want to play overwatch too again for you, but me think about that
Thank you peppermint for the extended membership real and true
Literally like oh, I will play this. Oh, we did it
Oh
Should have gone to opera instead of
Doing my naughty naughty voiceline. No, don't do it. Don't play like okay now
Sorry, I think I'm sorry. I might be under one without one. I just I've seen gameplay of it and I'm just like all right
Be cautious
Even with the flame at your command victory will not come easy
You have seen strong men weep and failure be not like them
What's wrong with crying if you didn't get what you like? Wow this game aged terribly
Men aren't allowed to cry if they fail me
Open your mouth dragon. I'm burping in it
Okay, right. I've got a fireball of a double fireball
Don't mess this up too much. Right. We're gonna like cut through these
Okay, that's perfect, but of course these stalls right on top right and then I've got a second fireball
So we're gonna cut through these ones
Okay, there we go. There she lives
Shawnee isn't real over until she has a discord kitten on team support now aren't I'm gonna see something controversial
Aren't you my discord can if you're willing to play the game just for me and enable me in game I
Doesn't that not make you the discord kitten and I'm the discord predator
Yeah, you like my deeper voice
Fuck she's right. I knew it. I knew I was right. Oh
No, I think I've messed up cuz I didn't break this one here. There's no way
Can I hit that can I hit that
We're dead I love games where I don't have to think about a single thing and I can't ramble
Oh
Your mastery greatly pleases me my students few are those who dare test themselves few
Right, let's do fire
Even if I get like one I'll take it. So we're needing a fireball like all through this. This is terrible
I wait until it comes over
Say hello, isn't that not that a
Elden ring game, but I'm on my own
I'm not playing any game where I want my own. I'm scared
I did push Elden ring back because of time and I'm sad but there's three endurance streams in a row of Elden ring
I
Believe it's the second week of September. It is both the weekends and a weekday
I have three 12 hour sessions and we'll see if that'll be
Controversial we are all your discord kittens cause we all want to help you in game
Exactly
That's exactly what we're saying for the legend. You're my district. Yay
Come on. That's right me out for mommy
Me or you're not getting oh my god. Wait, should I fuck with the reflands that are in my lobby and be like me
Or you're not getting heels from me and then they have to go me out. Oh
That's so mean
That's right bark down the mic for mommy or you're not getting healed
Four years in the team. Oh
I'm not making out
You're sick. You're a perverted woman. Yeah. Yeah, well, so you're gonna call me
Oh fuck, please hit the orange one all balls this
No, not I can do not I can do it both operate. Let's finish this tea. It's gonna be room temperature
Yeah, I'm a sick perverted woman and you entertain at all. That's right. I'm victim blaming you what you're gonna do
But absolutely nothing get get victim blamed. Oh
You're such a
Addicted kumar you can't you can't walk away
Heal me or I won't or I won't you my cute puppy
Hmm. Did you did you prefer eat that sentence before you sent it and now I said it out loud
And now everyone thinks I said it wrong, but then everyone's gonna look and chat and read the comment and it's wrong
That's right, I'm making fun of your English what you're gonna do better
That's right. I'm a bully
Billy's you harder
Women are scary. Wait, am I gonna scare you and boys tough I talk I don't want to scare you and boys tough. Oh, oh
This one's hard. Oh, no, I need the green. I need the green. Okay. Let's go for the good roads. Good boy
I'm not even gonna make it anyways in the last ball. Oh
All right, okay, let's try again this bright siren the bully art so for 15k special
I'm playing as your bully because I got messed up. I'm
And a role play and I was like you're the only person I can come to and then we fall asleep together in your bed
And I give you a kiss on the cheek and then our romance blossoms from there
But I've not thought of how I'm gonna extend the series, but I just know for 15k
I'm coming to you all beating up and I have like a bite mark on my thigh
I already showed the artwork actually I didn't mention it right finish the tea stop talking
Not like the top
Oh
It was a fire shit
Fireball I wasn't paying attention even though there's a clear audio
To quote a certain gen mate of yours. It's not grooming. It's true love. That's a sickle
Thank you darling go to you for this approach that was a sickle. That's it. I know I
Know that was a sickle. That's it. Oh, we're gonna do it. Can I reach this?
You ban you right surely. I'm not gonna fuck this up. Oh
We did it we did it surely a bite mark. Yeah on my Twitter war
Oh
Hold on a minute my name follower. Oh, no, you follow each other. Thanks fucking God, right? Oh, she's not tweaked out yet
Okay, but that's okay
Right if you're fucking bored of this that suit I have fantastic news for you
I have absolutely earth shattering
Perfect news for you. Okay
Absolutely ground-breaking news. Are you ready? Are you ready?
baby
Made collab and then the link surely this is the correct link and I'm not just linked something really fucked up in the background
Right, hold on. Let me make sure let me click that link. Okay. Oh
my god
Ah copyright. Oh my god. Oh my god the animator. See I got his animated as well
And then I look at Mary C's animated and then a meat on me. She's
Yeah, the anime really did a shit job actually he did it. He really
But yeah, oh my god, it's me. I'm moving. I'm a human and I have TD. Oh my god, it's me
Sorry right back to the gameplay. Hmm
Right, let me just do my little PR comment. Oh my gosh. Thank you
So even though we like agreed on this ages ago
Thank you so much for having me and my gen mates on your channel
I am so hit on it all our day the baby pink and I
Was I'm so hurried. Oh my gosh. Thank you so much. Oh, it's about that wrong for having me my gen
I'm so honored baby pink and then I'll do a little pleading face and then I'll do a little green heart
And then that is my customary thingy and then I'm gonna link it and I'm gonna put it in the discord
I'm gonna say
Put it in gen chat in the discord and put it don't forget to comment on baby pink's video. She went ham
Even though I did it all
Um
Right back to the gameplay. I will tweet out. No, I'll tweet out now because let's be honest. I'm gonna
live beans
Who the fuck are you calling a lady?
Sorry, that is a Scottish meme if you didn't know
I'm gonna tweet it out right now because I'm gonna forget to tweet it out if I don't tweet it out right now
So I'm gonna up hold the gameplay
Oh my god, I am so lucky
Hold on tweeting right now. Hold on. I am so lucky to say that
Me and well, it should be my gen mates and I actually I'm so lucky to say that my gen mates and I
Got the all pipette or unity to collab with none
Other than at baby pink
A
Her self so oh shit. Is that her v-tube and channel? Oh my god. She's gonna throw it on me
Is that her v-tube and channel or did she change it to oh my god? No
It's so much. It's so disrespectful to link. Oh my god. I almost linked the wrong fucking account
That's embarrassing
I almost linked her v-tubing account baby pink has two accounts, by the way
All right, I'm so lucky to say about gen mates and I got the opportunity to collab with none other than baby pink herself
So please check out when you have the need to snoo
when you have the need for some tingles or
a
sleep aid
And then I'll do
Made uh made. Oh my god. Sorry. This is how hard it is for me to do stuff behind the scenes
Do you see how long it takes me to do the most simplest task right?
I'm so lucky to say my gen mates when I got the opportunity to collab with none other than baby pink herself
So please check it out when you have the need for some tingles or a sleep aid exclamation mark green heart
Green heart, okay green heart got it and then next the link the link to the the the link to the fucking role play
Okay, okay, and then that's the link. Okay. Oh
Okay, post post
Okay, we're in play the game
Okay, it's on Twitter if you want to see it
Ha ha
Okay, we did it we did it no
I never on oh my god. We're about to finish the stream with the heck
I did not realize how short the campaign could be the way of the zen ball master hugh. Oh master. Who sorry
who
Why yes, I am who called master who by some
Wonder with me now as I hint at the mindful truth of my zen balls
Our journey will take us to where we are meant to be or maybe next door close enough
Okay, that's only why
Yeah
It is a truth that if the green peg is struck you will be blessed with zen ball zen ball seek harmony and goodness and all things
what
Right, let's hit this let's hit this green because I want to see what you do
I
What's a zen ball
Average twig
Hey
Oh the ai takes over even more
You ain't have to tell me to it. You do not have to tell me twice. I like that. I will
I will I will girl confirmed for gen two
You do not have to tell me twice. Oh my god
Someone a reflin sent me a
Brainworm message. Hold on. I'll check it out once we finish the campaign
A reflin had brain worms the bad idea. Stop having brain worms. You're overthinking everything
I'm spanking you
So not as good as magic hat is it not I feel like
This is getting quite
Oh my god, can I not hit the green? Okay, I can
How do you always end up on the right?
Are you trolling oh, maybe not I don't know was that trolling did they game troll a little bit there?
Oh, okay, hold on a minute. Maybe look how did I get that one though?
Oh
What how did I get it the straws in the way? I'm gonna have to hit it off of this one
Oh, there is no way I need I need better art and
How am I supposed to hit it like off? I would need to like hit it off of the wall here
That's absolutely shit. Don't do that. Um, I'm gonna have to bounce it off of this, I guess
Uh
Yeah, my speedrun records out the window. I'm afraid how was I even supposed to do that? No, go go on your
No, I just you've just put more there
You're making it up
Right. Yeah, I can only hit it if it's by like hitting it off other ones that are nearby
Well, I need the right side ones gone now or else I'm gonna be up shook free
No, it'd be dramatic or anything back
And it keeps putting the fucking
Go inside just go inside. Why?
Oh my god, I got all the awkward ones. Hold on. Don't throw don't throw
Okay, that was a throw shot, but that's because I'm dumb
Okay, okay
All the awkward ones are technically dealt with so I just need uh-huh. Uh-huh. Mm-hmm. Yes
Give me that serotonin
Is the is the sfx go?
Don't throw me out just yet. Don't throw me out. Get the orange one. Yes
Yes, right. I have three left. Okay
How did I do this?
Well, okay
Could have been better could have been better right. I'm leaving these ones in here
I didn't get it. I didn't get oh, I got the bottom one though, and I got a free ball. Oh, I love ball
Thank you. Just a hit it boss
No, that's not what I'm oh, thank god. I was gonna say that's not what I meant. Oh, we did it. Thank you
You
The tea is officially room temperature surprise surprise after 40 minutes of yapping
In life, there are many choices. Some are better than others
Then ball achieves one miss with bagel and improves the shot you are going to pick
Thank you. I'm shite. So
Wait, there's so many inside the center of this. How am I supposed to get in?
If it's other than by accident
Oh my god, that was so satisfying do it again
I creamed a little not gonna lie. That was actually really satisfying. Uh, can you do that again? Oh, it's a zen ball. Um
Are you able to like go for it over here and deal with these two?
Are we
Okay, I mean I got a free ball out of it
I don't know if I'm maybe just go for it. Oh
Fuck off
Does it take into account the moving things as well?
I have no idea. Oh my god. There's like nothing. Maybe I should have done the outsides first
There's like nothing to bounce off of out here. Oh, that was a good one. Um
There's nothing. Yeah, like at least I'm bouncing off his stuff
So it's not exactly like I'm just fucking throwing it halfway across the map like that blue is in the way of all them oranges
Hmm
No, I've no go at this
10 luck 20 skill 15 power of will 5 pleasure 50 pain 100 reason to remember the name
Okay, I fucked up. Uh, let's try again. Let's try again
Right you I'm avoiding the wisdom one
I want to do the outside ones first because they bounce against the the circle at least
And then like I'm hitting stuff accidentally by doing the outside ones
Let's see if this tactic pays off or if it's going to be sure
So
Zimbal OP
Does it give us
peace and tranquility? Can I get the orange one? No, right? I can't seem to get the orange one. So you
Pray in that you actually give me something I want but I feel like the game's just gonna
Oh, I did not mean to do it there. I should have done it in there
Unless
Oh my
Oh and I got the wee one over there too
Right, let me get that one
And then I'll start tackling the circle
Well, that was shite, um
And the blue one was in my waist because I wasn't paying attention. I think I just threw on ironically
All right, hold on. Can you guys think?
Like no
I
I'm I am very what is known as special needs. That's what's up
I've got two balls. Wait, hold on if I don't if I don't fuck this up
If I don't fuck this up
Okay, no, no, just let me go. I'm gonna run. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Ah, we did it. We did it
Uh
It was lurking but I thought you sounded nice trying to sing
Terrible you got 13 million points for
Zen balls work best when it has lots of options. You can open these options to zen ball by aiming for a peg
Or the corner
Whoa, there's portals
Now we're thinking with portals
What the fuck? Oh, it came out the honeycomb
Okay
I will try to keep that in mind. Oh, no, it's a zen ball
Oh, it's going it's going. Oh, she's off. She's off right go deal with the ones over here
I love a good correction shot
Oh, I just noticed there's a panel here. Ah
Ah, oh dear. That's not the best news
I've ever
Oh
Oh, look how there's a wee chicken in the background and there's a wee flying piggies
It's a pixie from viva pinata filled with fun
Right, so that's everything on this side done
So what I need to do that as if no, I think that was the right shot for the orange. Let's try again
Oh, what the fuck wait, so what a little to the left
Okay, yes. Oh my god. We didn't won. Okay, great
It's running a big one. Hi
Piggies, what's the brainware message? I just I can't remember what it was
Oh, it was a mark
It was like did you skip over my marshmallow and I was like, I thought they didn't get caught in the filter
But they might have unless it was something like kind of wildly inappropriate maybe to say on youtube. I didn't say it
But from the message, I don't think it was something inappropriate
um
because I think
You'd understand like why I wouldn't say it in the moment if it was like
anyway
Time for a breeding frenzy although I'm prayer. I don't really
Not see it. We just
We be substituting words out here edge in that last shot exactly
See with them blue ones are in my way get my way. There we go
That should have hit that orange, but I'll love it
I never even noticed that okay that
I
Don't know
Okay, hold on hold on hold on do
Uh, I need rid of those these blue ones this cluster of blue
Okay, let's go
Mine probably got felt I'm not good about I tried to avoid I hit on words
Yeah, I'll read out the once we finish because we just do a yapping. We'll do a yapping while we're
I love AI games where I don't have to think about it
Some stuff does get filtered. Yeah, I feel like hardly anything gets filtered
I've never had that comment before where I'm not ready to out and I'm like, oh
It it's made me question because I wasn't sure I wasn't sure
Oh
The true the power of zen balls to reveal your true potential every ball can be a zen ball
wait
Oh my god, but the owl is so right though for real for young
What uh
Very unique map. I'm not sure how I feel about this one
I feel like this is gonna be a bit more difficult than my usual tihi spam time
Uh, that's like a lot of blue as well
I'm gonna do the zen ball
I'm gonna shove it here and let the AI do the rest
That was the okay. Okay. Okay. No, not bad. Give him a shot. Give him a shot
Uh, I tested some stuff and found out that henlo often gets filtered and the message won't get
received. I don't know what this is
The filter just gives us new imagination on how to make mummy h word real and true though
Real and true
Even though they just move live it looks like they're spinning around like in a circle
Uh, sure
Uh-huh, uh-huh. Yes. Oh my god. Okay zen ball actual clutch though
actual factual clutch
Give me that 10 000
Um as for anything interesting
Emmy has a new short out ac has a new short out
The true test of a master master Bjorn unicorn
I scanned an avian. Well, then you have completed the bagel institute on the graduate program
with
Determination and player all that remains is the final exam
These levels will test your metal, but you may choose any master to help in your quest
I'm sure you'll do great after all you've here been taught by the beast
Wait the campaign's got more
Choose your character
Oh, no, who do we like the most you guys kept saying lucky rabbit
We're lucky rabbit we're lucky rabbit swoop
Hey, Bjorn
Bjorn from norwee. That's right. I was Bjorn here
You're making a mockery at Nordic I'm sorry
That's all I can say
You speak
Norwegian or just else can work. I mean
I love Norwegians
Hanging ding in Durgan
Wait, so me going and putting the accent on it's bad
But if a refland goes hanging ding in Durgan in chat, he just they get a spanking. What's going on here?
How am I getting a spanking when you're ten times worse than me?
Bjorn from norway norway
Or nor clear clear the bother spray
Beady beady beady beady
Oh for goodness sake, I'm doing scheisse
We've been making mock in italy's all week. I think a funny Nordic is having this
Hey, what is wrong with the Italian?
This is a shit use of magic hat, but whatever
Okay, this one's I'm not I don't think the rabbits a good one for this
Maybe the dragon for fireball just to cut through because this is
This is scheisse. This is scheisse on me
Do you be spiny?
Spinehounds
Eh, I think I have new shorts on the way as well. No, get them off. Give me the dragon. I'm gonna cut through this motherfucker's sign
It's okay mommy. I make a mockery of the language english then it's more strong. He's trying. Yeah, let the AI take over
Yeah is I admit it is last minute three. How was the optimum? Maybe like burning through to get the green again
As if I didn't ping up into the stratosphere and then like paying it through here
because these one
Oh, no, maybe these ones at the bottom here because that's like right at the bottom
Oh, as if that missed, right? I'm going to bed. That's ridiculous
Yes
Also, I use excited because it's soup day. It's finally time for me to make the soup and I'm so excited
So before anyone complains complaints. Well, actually you guys you genuinely never complain about my content
Which I find really surprising. I don't think I've had one fucking complaint a lot
Um, but it's soup day and I'm so excited. So I get to make soup
Uh, the chicken I've almost stripped it fully because I've been eating
Um, it's not so blacky. It's like a flat
bread
and then chicken
red onion lettuce
Sriracha and mayo and cheese. That's what I've been eating and like
I don't know
So obviously I'll order a lot of takeout because I can't be arsed after stream like cooking or
even ordering like a
The messages to come to the door like I can't be arsed with that
So I've been eating like tons of greasy food, but I'm not that greasy anymore
Like I used to be really greasy, but I'm not greasy. Like I had a shower
I feel I was like still feel super clean and everything and like I slept and all that
Um, Moomin was prepared to finish because she finished just quick. Oh, you're done. You're done a chicken and those
They got nanos on zealands
Oh, that actually wasn't even a bad attempt
Right try it on that. We'll give me one one
Greasy moment. Well, I'm not like greasy anymore. Like I used to finish a stream and I kid you not like the grease on my face
I was like for fuck's sake. What's going on here? Um, right zen shot. Just go for it. Do
Do I want to see
Destroy it from the inside out. Oh, that was gorgeous. That was love. That is absolutely lovely
That is gorgeous
gorgeous
Mummy's grease. I think we've finished the main campaign. So
What's that? My cane
Tomorrow is
Azur is
Beauty the trailer for her birthday went up. I don't know if it's serving ads or not because youtube was being a fanny
Hold on. I'm I'm literally going on Azur's youtube channel to see if it's serving ads or not
YouTube was being such a wee willy
No, that's a hard to serve
Hey
Hey, she be seems a skincare type so she gave oh no, it's just because I'm a filthy fucking gamer
That's it. There's literally there is nothing that will motivate me to actually look after myself
In terms of like, oh skincare routine. Oh, this is the I could need you less of a fucking shite
I just could maybe ask the way up
Um
So
It's really on me. It says no one can fix me. Okay. You can't fix me. I'm just lazy as fuck
Uh, literally just rot away and play video games. That's all I do. Ain't much right
I'm gonna have to get rid of these blues or I literally cannot shoot
Cannot shoot. I don't even know if that's gonna help
Drat
Oh come on
Um
No, fuck you. What were you use the power of flower to light up 20%
No, what were jack caused the boss to quickly reappear at the top of the screen after falling off the bottom
Um
Let's give jack a lot of energy
Well, at least you have no pee balls, right?
Why are you wanting to drink them?
No, I do not have pee balls
I'm not that far gone yet. Although I did consider it at one point
But that was many years ago. That was many years ago
But I I don't have the appendages for it. I'm gonna be honest if I had the appendages for it
I'd probably go for it like uh, you know
It's a generous
I'd probably piss balls and poop socks the truth
I really hope poop socks isn't real, but I think it might be because people have made reference to it
Which makes me nervous. I'm getting I'm getting a little shaky. Okay. I'm getting scared
Oh look at that one
This might be forbidden knowledge, but I know a girl who keeps a device for doing that standing up
It worked in a bolt. Oh, I'm not sure I'd voluntarily do that
I just pee in the shower
Like whenever I go for a shower it just my brain is like mmm pee time and I'm like, okay pee time
I don't know why folk are like, oh my god, peeing in the shower is so gross. What are you on about?
seriously
Shitting and waffle stomping in the shower. Yeah, I draw a line too. Don't get me wrong, but piss fucking relax
Yes, okay speaking of piss. I'm pissing up my shots
Okay, okay, geez it all goes down the drain. Yeah, I don't really know the whole oh my god
Peeing in the sink. That's out of the question as well. I wouldn't pee in the sink. That's not
That's not ladylike. No, it's fucking me
That wouldn't be in the sink in general. I don't see why that would be
any
then
Not by a long shot
That's some screwed up play to a fun factor
I thought everybody peed in there. I don't know. I just remember folk arguing being like, oh my god, peeing in the shower is so gross
And it's like, who are you arguing with because it's not me
I'm pissing right now
You're not a sink pier. No, I don't know. I don't know why you would pee in the sink
right
Sebastian. No, that one was shite. What are you uses super advanced to light up nearby peg
I threw another ball into the mix
Oh, let's do jimmy leiden
It's better to pee in the sink than to sink in the pee
I have to admit. I agree with that word
Wise words of wisdom for from minicaric. Thank you for the super chat. That is wise. That is rather wise and not as stressful
Peeing in the shower makes it smell awful. Wait, how doesn't it all just go down the drain or am I going crazy?
Because I think you're crazy
Am I crazy? I don't know how it works
Oh, no way that second ball spawns on the one over there, right? I'm not playing this guy again
Are you ever seen the kevin bridges? Who took a shite in my kettle? I know that sounds absolutely bizarre
I promise I'm gonna force you to watch scottish humor
um
But there was this joke by kevin bridges and he was uh, and it like had the whole
Nation in an uproar because it was just hilarious like the whole nation was he hawing over this joke
But I must do a kevin bridges watch along. I even know if I can grab it actually
Might be a bit awkward to grab but we'll see we'll see
If not, I'll just
Hmm, I don't know how I would do it
All right, what is with these bonus ones? These aren't even easy. These are like ridiculously hard, right?
I'm not playing the hamster. You should go away
Go away, right who?
Maybe fireball did I do fireball?
I don't know. I just I don't know
It is so difficult
Are they all right? No, you know feel well when I'm trying to hit as well. No get get the ais banking honestly
Right, let's get rid of that one and that one because that's like oh, maybe these four
Oh wait, I didn't have a I thought I had a fireball for some reason
Am I special?
Yes
And that's okay
Trust magic hat. Are you sure?
I will do bunny again because I'm losing hope. I'm losing copium right now
It doesn't even bounce like a regular ball
Also, did I tell you is there a randomly put CVT into the discord?
She thought it wasn't a real she thought it was a fake pee pee
And she put actual CVT in the discord and all of us were like what the fuck?
And it was hilarious like she
Azura has no idea how accidentally he'll like hilarious. She is so fucking funny
She is so funny. She was like wait, it's real and we're like
Azura you can see the squish on the freaking pentas
So it was it was that one where the guy has like a cardboard box over everything
and his wee
Egg and soldiers is hanging out and then it was I think it was either woman's barefoot just standing on it or
In heels, maybe it was the barefoot one. I think it's the barefoot one right trust in the magic ball apparently
um
and uh, all of us were like, uh
And she was just like, oh, I thought it was fake and I'm like never changes or I love you never change. That's hilarious
Hey, did you hear the guy screaming? I mean I can play it right now. Hold on
Hold on let's get it up. This is I don't know if you'll recognize it
Oh, it's in shoes
Okay, it's in shoes. That's what she said
Is it necessary?
Is that the stomping you have a stomping in shoes?
I don't know. I don't know how that could feel
Good am I going mental I'm saying that's bizarre
Mummy stop it life
Everybody likes cognitive behavioral therapy. It's great
It's good. Okay
frickin spooky balls
Get them spooky balls here. I never even did anything good. Oh, let's really just wrecked me
Hoi hoi, it's a guy not in pain. Thanks friend. But that's what I'm saying like isn't that agonizing?
Who what do you get over it? But then again
Who am I a judge? We're all here for a good time. Who am I a judge? Who am I a judge?
Uh, yeah, is there a had a new patreon upload which was makeup?
After you fight and she does like a fake attempt at sph time small people time, but the reality is
Your
This is so juicy and oh main break in that she can't take it anymore
She was trying to
Hardcore of masochism is not meant to feel good. It's meant to be so bad. We're good now. This ain't happening anymore
Bruh, I will give the lucky rabbit one more time, but I think we're actually stuck. I'm not even kidding. I think we're stuck
genuinely
a
Hey, what's going on?
Oh
I prefer cuttlefish
I prefer cuttlefish bondage training now get on your knees puppy
Now hold on a minute
Thank you the pretty lord now. Hold on a minute
Hmm, I'd be worried about not just me for the actual damage since there are several nerves and little veins
You have to focus on the ball getting to swing down the loops towards the center
Mmm
Yes, I
Why is there no anti gravity keep the hat on no stop perishing in the just
Oh the game hates me not I'm raging
That's it. Bellatrous getting started early. There's no way
Cut. Where's my serotonin? It's no here
Uh, where's my serotonin? Where is it? Where are they?
Where's my serotonin I don't have serotonin
Come on. I can't ink at least let me win in a video game
Rattling the cages right now
Give me my serotonin right Sebastian. I'm not doing you. What are you light up all nearby pegels?
I mean that clears out a lot okay
You need to ask for permission first it's straight up broken. I've not
Zoinked my zinger
Son
Any anyone zonking their zinger right now
I'm zonking so hard
Um
Yeah, like it's just back in broken
I'm too stressed. But as I said the video game's away. So I don't have to deal with that
Uh, the peaches club is lasting on my agenda and I honestly think that
I can focus on all me we tasks now
Um
Oh, I give up I give up
I give up this is going to turn into a marshmallow stream in about a minute. Give me my serotonin
Give me ma
I even know how to do this right we can at least get that orange one there
Right, okay. Don't write me out yet. How about this far too high
Far too not low enough shit
Right, how do I hit that one?
Have faith
Bing
What a oh no, I don't know. I don't know
No
So go lower
No, I did it again. Okay higher higher so it hits the blue
No
I'm actually special needs
What was that playing in that one right alien you seem your alien blast seems to be really freaking good
It's okay. You did good. Thank you for comforting me
The math ain't nothing. I'm done
I'm so freaking close
I'm gonna far
I'm gonna fart so hard right now
I'm farting. I'm tooting everywhere
Bro, what was that noise that was me being absolutely raging
I'm
I just want to win. I just want my tiddly winky serotonin. Is that too much to ask mr. AI?
Just give me my tiddly winks
And before the ai's like you're literally playing so bad. We can't rescue your shots
Look, I'd believe it. Honestly, I'd believe it wholeheartedly. I'd believe it. Oh, I got a free ball
Right
Oh, that was terrible
Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah. No, you should have hit the orange hit the orange. No, it doesn't
It doesn't hit the orange over there and the orange is behind frick him
That was actually really lucky. I'm like, I'm getting right. Surely this is a wall shot
Down a bit
Please
Yes, oh my god, this took me so long. Maybe the alien is who I need
Um
AI in this game the the game like AI takes over your shot
Finally inking right now. I'm inking so hard master state. Wait, what does that mean?
I don't know what that meant
Right, we're doing the alien
Get out of here
Who are how are you supposed to be doing this in?
Let's do the blast
Let's do the blast since apparently that was wrong
Um, can I do that? Well, that was a terrible idea
Oh
I'm not liking the look of this. Yeah, I'm not liking the look of this. Yeah
I think you might have to write me out. I've only got five balls left already
I must stomp on them because what sorry that was a zero talking not me
Um
Right
Right, right. Um, I definitely don't think the alien's the one for this one
Maybe try like pachinko won't just go anywhere or is there tactic to pachinko? I don't know about
Yum, right not alien. Who should we go for dragon? Maybe to burn through entire sections
If I can even get it right well clearly I'm leaving a lot to get it because what was that?
We'll try dragon. Maybe we can get a cheeky burn through sections
I was hoping it would ride it a bit better rider
Just say you hate me it's easier than than being denied because what is this?
This is the worst
Who are you supposed to like literally who are you supposed to play as?
I'm gonna pass away
And on my gravestone. It'll be because uh Peggle didn't give me my missing serotonin. I can't believe that
Yes, I am blaming the game
No, I will not take responsibility for being a bad Peggle player
Can you go in there?
Stop skip!
Ah
I can't even have access to the greens
I literally can't even hit my ultimate. I'm gonna have to play the dragon again and hope it comes to me
So just try and get the rose but the rose hate me the balls like going flying down. They're not like leaning against it
I didn't even got my but look give me a green you. Yes. Give me a green now
Right and then what we're going to do is burn the fuck through all of these go
Oh my god, I hate the bounce because it's not right. Oh wait if I just made this 10 times worse for myself
Mm-hmm, I think I've made this 10 times wrong
One advantage of the dragon is dragon these knots. No, you're not maybe a little bit
Right gently no
I can't believe it dragons these nuts on my face. Thank you the baby
What's the other one? Oh, would you guys ever go to solcon with me?
Because I know I've spoken about the meet-up before and there's this convention called solcon
Oh
Solcon like me so God these nuts
Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here
I know I know I'm just so good like that my last ball right. I'm not playing dragon your shape for this
He girls are I ladies I ladies nuts on your face
Right who
Should I just fucking go to the sunflower? She likes how fuck you they are boom. Oh, no, she does it to the nearest five
Right me sunflower. I got a free ball
Oh
Oh my oh my
Okay, I don't know how I'm supposed to win this
I am too illiterate in the gaming to know what the game
Okay, that was satisfying though. I'll give you that
But I can't get that angle like on everything. I can't get it
I don't know who I'm supposed to be
Maybe would Bjorn tell me if I could like do a five six day off someone's toilet
Hmm that was a good start and show us the theory but try your first shot at the top of the row
No, you're just gonna have to remote hack into my content
Because this isn't working
I got lucky ball though. Oh, no, there's a blue in the way. Tee hee. Oh, well that was lucky
Well, I could have got another ball. Yeah, like I'm literally nothing I can do it's all in the way of each other
Bagel exactly
The main trick is to reflect them back and forth. It has to be from the boot. Right. I'm doing I will
Right if I do it top it norm
If I do it this way now will you go down there you go
Oh
Right, and then if I go this way it will all tail it to do something
No
What
You're tearing me apart bagel. Oh, hi reeflings
Oh, no, that's not the core was it
reeflings
I did not hit her. I did not hit her. Oh, hi reefling something like that. That's the best second. I've never seen the movie
I don't know how to get it in
Okay
I'm already a boss
Yeah, and I put my
On your job
late
I don't even know what the AI is going to suggest
Oh, yeah, it just gave me a last but I mean, oh, I'm
It
I'm not gonna make it I did not ink on her. I did not it's not true. It's bullshit. I did not oh, hi strong
What I love about the room is that all the pictures are spins what in the background?
Okay, this must be a reference I don't know
Oh my god, am I becoming Peter good real?
And I'm her my
I'm not making it when a guy she mass right. That's it. I'm
I'm opening up marshmallows
I can't handle this
I'm getting depressed playing freaking as to where if the balutro stream goes worse than this is over
Not even the soup will bring me back
Even though I'm actually really excited to play with it play with the soup
What the fuck no to produce the soup to make the soup to harvest the soup
To roast the vegetables to cut the vegetables. I'm gonna put my tavern music on in the background
Oh dear traveler
Balutro is also a thinking game. No because you guys tell me what to do
So I don't have to think
So that's such a strong star and I threw away I threw
No
Copium
Can I get you to hit that one off the wall?
Oh
I take it back. I love this game. Let's continue. I take it back. I take it back
I take it back. I love this game. We're gonna continue. Let's see what the next map is all about
Maybe the owl is the way to go the owl is the way to go. I repeat right
Let's analyze analyze the map. We've got a resource serve. We've got we put our
analyzing
10 shots
And that's it. Wait what?
Okay, so if we get in the flying saucer, it'll put us back up. I guess forgive us another chance
Right, let's get rid of all the oranges up here and then we'll deal with all the ones down the
Oh, wait, hold on a minute. Do I need to do the flying saucer ones first?
How am I even supposed to deal with that?
Oh
Mist all right, I'm just throwing sorry. I just felt like it. I felt like being quirky
Hashtag throwing for my chicken soup
Yeah, I was like research. I was like don't need to soak red lentils overnight
But I think it's a broth mix that you need to soak overnight
Oh, wait, I wasn't
I didn't realize I was at the end shot my bad
Um, right, so I need to put it in the
What I was trying to attempt just put it in the we
Oh, wait, I need to shove it in here
When it drops over what I want it to go down
Um, I'm not even sure how that came out so badly
Right damn right you're giving me a free ball after that because what the fuck was that
Yeah, fuck was that honestly now go
No, I'm gonna fart
I'm gonna fart. I'm gonna do it
Right, I've wasted a few shows. Let me let me just hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Don't write me. I'm just
Let me entertain you for one
That one song let me
Play this game perfectly better
She fired deeply departed. I truly just farted
Right, please I'm begging begging begging you
I'm sorry you have to listen to my remixes of songs just close your eyes at this moment
Just believe
I'm closing so hard right now. All right, what do I need to do? Do I need to get that green? I feel like an
If I get that green and then shove it through the portal do I win?
Tie a mox tie a mox
Well, that was a pitiful attempt. Oh, well, I got the green
So flash up the green through the portal is it gonna know that I want to put it through the portal?
Or do I need to take your
Fuck it. Fuck it. I'm just sending it. I don't know
Uh-huh. Okay. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
I got a bit excited. Okay, I got a wee bit excited. Just ski. I'm out. Give me a thing
Right anytime. Okay. I was a bit early. I was a bit late. I was a bit late. Okay. Nice
Uh-huh
That was far too early
I just need that green one to come and clutch instead of come in peace we come and clutch
Right just do it let the ai take over
It's okay, we got a free ball
Mm-hmm
Okay, we got another one I'm going on don't write me out you were gonna do it you were gonna write me out
Oh
Okay, okay. I think the owl is the way to go
I think the owl is the way to go because the ai is
Unless maybe dragon fire. All right, the alien blast doesn't really seem to be it. Um
The magic hat you guys swear by the magic hat. I swear by
Not that
Hashtag sus. Um
Sure. Just go for it
Are you squidding me right now?
Came across this poem in a public bathroom here. I sit broken hearted came to shit, but only farted
Why
Is it real that guys struggle to poop a lot like
Oh, I'm gonna you know, I'm gonna do an anonymous poll
I must know I must know if this is true or not. Thank you the booty lord because you're starting a poll
Uh
I need to know
Okay, I need to know I need to know it's the most disgusting poll ever that I will ever ask
I'd for some reason always hear stories about guys needing help to shit
Do you are you squeezing like are you having to be like on the toilet like
Like what's going on? Are you okay? I need to like make you some roast veggies help that fiber going. Um
Literally like does your face turn red like the meme?
Not chill like
Not to get
Not to get anything right no no to get like political or anything
But if I need to go to the toilet, I just come flying out and then I'm done like I know I'm sorry to get political on the main but
I don't know. Yes. No. I turn I turn red. Um, unless I'm sick. No, I'm doing fine. Usually
It's flat. Well, like if I need the toilet, I'm like ready to evacuate. Okay. We're gonna end the poll there
That's absolutely foul. No, you cannot prove
No, you cannot prove do not prove
Wait, what
Oh, I forgot about the wait
Thing I'm an idiot. I completely forgot there was a wait thing in the way
I literally forgot the barrier was there
And we're a constipated bunch, right? That's it. Everyone is now putting on 10 milliliters of my apple juice
Because you're all dehydrated
Clearly you're all dehydrated. What's going on here?
I love when I accidentally do a free ball out of nowhere
This is too hard
Show Tomati
No, that is so good. I'm so sorry. Sorry
I'm so sorry. Sorry. Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. I'm so sorry
God speed refling and you need need toilet time help. Oh my poor reflin
I've had to shit so hard that blood came out of our reflin. No, don't push that hard
No, I'm a poor reflin
Are you just gonna have to let me be your booty doctor? Sorry. This is how it is. All right. I have to
Surely I'm not gonna I can only take it at a left angle
Oh, I hit it right. How do I hit? Ah, fuck it. Let's just don't look I can't
One
Hey, right, you know, I don't need clipboards that shake
I
Spooky boz
I don't know. We'll try alien. I don't know
Magic hat shit. I should have a magic hat. You're right. Right. We'll do magic hat. We'll do magic hat
Write this one off write this one off because there's no way
I
Been at this too long AI just take the wheel already
It's no clicking. You know, it's not clicking either. This is like what my fifth attempt or something
You know, it's not clicking
You know, my brain's not getting it. Just give me what I want. Give me what we're here for
Yes
And a free bow
Why can't we bow?
Come on
um
Flippers might be good. You can throw the ball back up again
You might be right Ken Ken. What I can't what I can't get right. I actually can't get right. Yeah, right
Hey, we'll try rabbit and then we'll try Sebastian Rekima. Thank you for the extended membership. Happy demand
You know, if we had a baby its wee eyeballs would be developing
It still looks like a peanut, but it's starting to develop some stuff
Oh my god, we're pregnant right now. Wait on there. What wait am I gonna?
I'm just trying to think
I just if everything goes to plan
Uh at the nine month membership mark I might actually be pregnant with gen two
If everything
What am I doing? I don't know what I'm doing. I'm just throwing. Sorry. It's this one. I should be doing tihi
Sir
I was awful go again
That was even worse
Hmm our children real. I think so. I think if the membership hits nine months, I'll be pregnant with gen two
The father me of course exactly the lights go off and we all go for oh
All right, I think I'm just trolling now because I'm complaining about no
I'm gonna bite my mouse. I am going to bite the mouse
Uh-huh. Yeah, I'm biting my mouse right. We'll do rabbit and then we'll do Sebastian
rabbits
rabbits give me the fucking hat no
And what does triple score do give me an extra
We life are we actually balls the lights go off at nine months pregnant? No, the lights go off on october
October 10th is when we find out if I can make 69 dollars during my daughter's
Um
I'll I'll
Um hydration check with water got water
um
BRB gen two daddy's going for milk. Oh my god, you're not gonna stick around for your children
refling
You're not gonna stick around for your veins
And to see what you've produced
Reflin the baby would be the size of a kidney beam
Little kidney bean would be so cute. Oh, I want to learn how to make chili like the beef chili
That's maybe
Something I'll update you on as I said if my soup goes well, all you're gonna hear me is I'm gonna have to mute if I eat
Soup on stream though. There's no way people are gonna want to listen. Oh
Oh
I am Sebastian under the sea
Ocean together
Oh
Uh, right. Yeah. Okay. Well, I'll come oh
Oh, right. Okay. Let's do that. Let's do this
Soup is smart. No, there's no way I'm slurping. I do have uh audio of me drinking out of uh
I'll say it was the dog bowl, but it was actually my my cat's bowl
I gave it a good wash and then I was looking milk out of it for asmr
But I have no idea if I can even put it on youtube because youtube is being really weird about asmr
And I don't know what's going on
Like they're being real
Did that just no I couldn't have
Oh, please
Please baby. Give me one more
Right I need to go earlier. Hold on. Let him go back
And then
Yes, okay. How did I hit the other one?
Oh
That was far too late. That was far too late. Sorry. I keep covering my mouth so my model keeps falling asleep
I'm a terrible pilot maker right you go away. Sebastian your time of shine
All right, don't let me down. I won't thank you Sebastian
Drinking milk my yes, I don't know if I can even put it on youtube because if I was literally lapping up I was like
I'm like you can hear me like I'm actually doing it. It's not there ain't no fibrinos going on like I'm literally going
We're getting talk so plasmosis for this one. Yeah, I was literally a milk drinker
What do I do a milk drinker? Yes. Thank you for asking. I drink all the milk
All right, let's see get that orange win
I'm gonna spank my clothes tonight
Thank you. Thank you clothes. Okay get away. Uh
I don't even know how to hit that orange one over there
I'm lich. Yeah, I was gonna say I'm lich. I have to waste
So many to get this orange one
What do you mean this game is hard?
Someone said there's a game called peggle after dark and I'm like what the fuck is going on in after dark
Do I need to know?
Oh
You're exciting boy. Yes. No
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Sorry. I'm like sweating. I'm sweating right now
I'm sweating. Can I get this to go over here somehow?
Wait what
Am I going mental? How did the physics even do that? Just more peggle, but the levels are the master's dreams
Stroney pegle and after that. Well, literally that's what I thought when I heard I was like peggle after dark
Uh
Oh, I can okay. Okay. Hold on. No
No
Right, okay one more time right. We'll try Sebastian again because that was on one. So let's just do that
So no ball so no head rip
Rip oh someone clicked me when I was like, I'm gonna do a aggressive scottish ASMR
And everyone was like, yes, we want that and I'm like you want aggressive angry ASMR
Sometimes in this game you get peggled or get pegged and I've been getting pegged for the past how long
I have made zero progress. I've made zero progress
Whoever designed the bonus levels. Yeah, mom's a whole
Aggressive farting ASMR win. I did burpen actually
I was looking at the reasons why like people have left the patreons
Just to see like general feedback in that because sometimes people are a bit more brutally honest when
It's like anonymous feedback
On patreon and someone was like not uh, someone said no vor yet
Someone said uh, no burp audio and I'm like, I did an entire 20 minute audio me burping and drinking and gulping sounds
What do you mean? There's no burping
Well, what what do you mean? There's no burping. There's a whole audio on it
Wait, what were done other than horrific?
How am I even doing that?
Okay, let's go. Oh, okay. Got the blue. So scoop my way and I got the ball back
Okay, so on the way back surely it's gonna hit something
And it hit a blue again. I don't want blue. I want red add some wraps
yeah
Because obviously I want to make people as happy as they are and you know the content that they want
That's why I think especially in the later months. Uh, I think all four scripts are going to be written together
Uh, like we'll write it and you'll get exactly what you want because
Um, you guys come up with better plots than I do half the time honestly. Um
Although a sheebie
Wants to write all of her october and I'm so excited for her but I had to break the bread news
To her she was I don't I'm not gonna say what the plot was but she wanted to do a plot that wasn't necessarily
allowed and I was like, I'm so sorry to break your heart, but it's not allowed
Um, because she literally typed no and I'm like, I'm sorry. It's just the way it is
If they break the news we are slaves to mastercard all hail our overlords at mastercard. We love you
Hey, thank you for
Oh, okay
Like I'm gonna be honest. I don't have much faith. I'm sorry. I'm just
Sorry
Oh, yeah, just wrap it up. Oh, right. Okay. Try again. Try again. This one is so hard for no reason
I don't even know if I could hit the other one. I'm gonna sneeze for a minute. Good morning. Oh
Wow, the game really wants me to win. It's trying so hard to let me win
I'm picking at the wrong time. Just
Just let the a I take over seriously. Just take over right who
Sebastian go to space. I don't need you
Magic hat. I the reeflings are swearing by this freaking magic hat. So I'm doing magic hat
The mastercard and visa branch aren't actually behind the whole we don't
It turned out it was something like distributing things overseas
I don't know. I find that hard to believe because they're all jumping on Epstein Island
So is so is but how many can swear to see they're all jumping on Epstein Island. So what the fuck are they on about?
Distribution
Hello, I'm a consenting adult
Uh, no bad ban. Okay
Look, I'm sorry. You're probably right. I'm just I I feel so doubtful just because
I'm I'm just a terrible doubter. Okay
Like I'm allowed to be salty if it literally stops me from fucking writing the roleplays that I want
Because let me just tell you
My patreon would be fucking diabolical if I could write exactly what I want
Absolutely diabolical. Emmys patreon would be fucking atrocious
If I was at the helm of the scripts and she let me write what I wanted to write
It would be fucking died. We'd be cancelled in like three seconds. Well, I don't care
The magic hat itself is not that powerful. It's the belief in the hat that makes you win
Well, maybe
All right, okay, we're doing a talos. Let's win
All right, just suck. I just suck admit it you suck
And I'm gonna swallow so hard fascinating
All I'm saying is
I love the girls
I love the way they're designed. They're that they're the best design
Hey, did you hear about be dairy a reefland sent me a message and they were like they might have beaten you on a design
You wanted and I'm gonna cry so hard
Uh, I really want everyone to be like I give up. I actually give up. I give up. I give up. I'm not thinking
I'm not thinking. I'm not no stop. Let's stop it. I'm not thinking just
Just put the ball in the bag. That's it. I'm putting supermarket simulator on actually I'm
That's it. I'm going back. I'm going back to my real job
I was sitting at chill on a gun remember that
Right I will time and then I give up I will time and I'm just reading marshmallows
I give up after this one if it doesn't work. I give up
I
Thought this was supposed to be an easy game the peggle championship dreams in the shower literally
Who's spade ran this? What's the speed running record because I know for a fact I ain't getting it
It's gonna be blinks all over again. No
I'm just gonna accept that. We uh, we ain't playing peggle on the channel after this one because it's a different
They didn't take your head
um
I'm sure whatever vial thing you come up with won't match the debauchery of marques. They saw julia. Wait, what?
Do I want to take that up?
Hold on. We're doing live research. Look. We're in the digital age ladies and gentlemen
And by ladies and gentlemen, I mean the one percent lady
Which is what I've typed in what you've said julia is a novel written by a published accompanying
Uh
He was imprisoned for it
He invited prostitutes to his little house and subjected them to a
Okay, well, that's enough for that for today
Uh
He wasn't a very nice man. Let's sum it up to uh
And
He was imprisoned when the catholics ruled brandy else. His name is literally where we get the term sadism for
Monka
Right, what what I need to I need to hit this orange one so I need to get rid of that blue one
Um, yes. Oh, yes, age me harder
Yes, okay. Well
I don't really want that if I'm being honest
I don't
I mean
Oh, if it could have got that one, maybe we were in for the rankings, but
I'm more likely in for a shank and thank you. I'll be here all week. Uh, that doesn't even make any sense
Oh
Have you heard of that meme where you're supposed to expel all the air and then try and scream
I feel like if I did it, I would pass out. So I would like to try it. Maybe when I'm feeling better, but
I feel like I'd pass out if I attempted out
Dissuade. Yeah, he literally is the word sadism comes from
She's gonna meet you
Hello, everybody. I'm Hudson Miku
Konnichiwa
I don't know how to sound like Hudson Miku again
I'm thinking Miku, Miku, Miku, Miku
Inhale scream
Oh
Wait, what?
Ah
I sound like a seagull
You were breathing right now. Fuck you. You're getting harsh clues get fucked off. I'm not playing that game. I'm not playing that shit
I'm not playing that shit. Get off the screen. I'm not playing it anymore. I'm rage quitting. Yes. I'm rage quitting pago hardy har har
Get that shit. Get that beta shell by screen. Go away. Wait. Whoa. That's not what I meant to do
Right
Okay, I'm reading marshmallows. I give up on region. I'm farting
Oh, I'm not reading that shit no more
I'm not playing that shit no more literally rage quitting off of pago. I don't care. Sorry. I have a maid collab to deal with
And by deal with I mean review. Okay. Fuck it. We're just reviewing the maid collab lives
Okay, here's where I could have improved the audio and here's where I messed it up
Get peggles. I got peggles sometimes in this world. You get peggled and I got peggled. Okay
I've got peggled so hard
Hey mom, did you say chili? Here's a lazy version of my family recipe. Oh my god
I could make family recipes of your guys's family's recipes
And then I can force myself to be a part of the family and then you can write me in the will
And then I can start the veal or empire where we take down the high table
Genius
Okay, let's read the family recipe. We're all going to judge it together family and friends love it. I hope you do too
A pack of ground beef a white onion not a red onion. You don't use red onion in that dish a bell pepper
American identified you mean
A pepper or a capsicum
For some reason in Australia. They're called capsicum. I don't know why
I mean, he's got it coming out. So
One can of kidney beans one can of tomato sauce two celery
Two mush two cans of sliced mushroom. Wait, that's a thing cans of sliced mushroom
I didn't even know that was a thing
I've never seen that before
What? I didn't know. I would just buy them fresh
Uh paprika
I read paprika
family
I'm introducing you to your mom. Could you imagine me walking in like our own the place? I'm like, oh, no, no
I don't invite me here. It's fine. Hi. I'm strongy
And then when I leave your mom's just like
You're forbidden from seeing her again. There's something clearly wrong with her
Um four tablespoons of cumin powder four four tablespoon garlic powder two tablespoon chili powder
One teaspoon of black pepper
Chicken bullion. Fuck yeah, I need to go buy that chicken bullion because I messed up heat the pot add oil cook
What who goes there brine tonight on the melbourne news
Scottish woman uses legal loopholes to become part of thousands of families worldwide and has become the richest woman in the world
overnight
I'll do it. I'll fix the economy. Hashtag slags fix the economy 2024
Thank you tiny spiny
For the key up
I'm strongy. Your child calls me mommy too
Hi there your son calls me mommy too strongy supermarket together free on steam meet the reflings in the back room for morale meeting
I do actually want to play more of that game because it looks so fun
Hey, like like it looks so fun. I didn't get very far
But I want to play it more. I wish it was multiplayer. I'd go feral if we could run a supermarket together
Um, right heat the pot add oil you use olive oil. I use extra virgin oil
Moms be like, I don't care my home give me grandkids grandkids
grandkids
Kick the onion beef add the veggies add the spices and some billy on smell makes
Lord heat let us do it for two hours
Serve with sour cream cheese green onion
I wouldn't have served it green onion and of course garlic bread garlic bread. Yes. I approve. I approve. I approve
Invited to the kicker
I use the slutty olive oil parrot. Yeah, I use the shagged olive oil
Please let us hear some of your absolutely diabolical ideas that aren't allowed on patreon
I need to know how unhinged my cutfish wife is also twitter is pretty good alternative. Yes, it is it is
Oh, yeah, that reminds me strongy. Did you ever decide?
Decide what?
Oh, don't oh, don't be you can't send me that
I'll talk about my unhinged plots in the membership stream
But what did you someone says? Oh, yeah, that reminds me. Did you ever decide decide what?
I don't know. I'm small brain
I'm so small brain. What do you mean?
Mommy you live rent free in my head now. I can't stop thinking about you when all the fun streams are lurking in the chat
Yeah, you're lurking. Have you have you dared to post or are you just lurking in the shadows? Are you scared?
Are you scared you're gonna spell the spaghetti in front of me?
Is this the part where I reassure you that I'm spaghetti fight out the wazoo? I literally I just verbally
Word vomit all the way through stream
And you're still shy of me
You're still shy of me and you hear me
You hear me day in day out and you hear the things that my brain comes up with and you're shy
That's okay. You're allowed to be shy
You don't have to talk if you don't want to do
strongy
Yeah
Surely you can put the lips of the bottle on your smaller secondary hole for pain, right?
Uh, so that way it doesn't spell oh when I pee it goes all down my thighs and stuff
So I am not risking standing up and doing it like that
I ain't risking it. I ain't look. I'm happy to go to the toilet when I need the toilet. Put it that way
We only complain when you don't keep take care of yourself get nutrition get sleepy to get slept get hydrated
Okay, I'll hydrate right now
We're more are wordable when we're shy real and true
Thank you. I have hydrated refund. Thank you. Get completely loved on you nerd
Yeah, what happens if I love on you next?
I'm gonna love all over you. Gonna my lovely lady loves check it out. Well
Our lady lumps boobs
If so, we might have a problem with that. However
I have fantastic news in the bakery department
This is for the brain wormlings. If you start a mario message with generic greetings like hello
Hey, or hi, there's a chance it gets filtered for spam. It is rare, but keep that in mind if the message is important
Hi, scrawny kind of a generic question, but since it's almost been four months, I ain't even reached the three month mark yet
Are you shoving me of the door?
Uh, so what's your favorite game to play at the moment?
Now I'm really biased, but I thoroughly enjoyed that black ops one stream. That was really fun
And she missed when chat tried to tell her reeflings. Maybe this is
I'd say black ops was hella fun. Hold on. I'm gonna go down a trip
I would say I'm really biased but the hypno stream
I did not expect to get so many compliments over it and people being like, thank you for not taking the piss out of hypno content
I was like, oh
You love me. You love me. You're so nice to me
I'm excited to see how the hypnosis stream goes tomorrow. No in two days time
Um, I like black
I I'm gonna check my other streams. Hold on
Yeah, hypnotize. I like right
So the 15k thai cam celebration that was fun to be so teasing, but I was so worried
I was gonna get in trouble for it by uh, our overlord. I love brotherhood, but I can't wait to take another whack at it
Uh, even though I got really sick after ring fit adventure. I enjoyed having a carry on just going mental. Halo. I liked
um
Just because it was halo. I loved how shitty I was playing like it was terrible viva pinata love sonic heroes
That was really good to play as well
um buckshot roulette was really nice
um
I'm biased. I just like all my streams. I think it's because you're there
I'm not allowed to say that. I think I just enjoy all streams because you're there
sonic heroes
Oh
I'll give you a sneak peek on how the hypnosis dream goes. I'm gonna
I'm excited for the next one. Yes. I'm gonna be very nice in it. Um
I know take it easy. All right. Hope I'm gonna push through my exhaustion because I'm up at
Well, the stream starts at 2 a.m
I'm gonna have to wake up at 1 a.m to smack myself awake and drink as much tea as I can
Without making my stomach go crazy and go
Oh
Hi cuttlefish
Refling here had a strange dream this morning that I was in a college
Classroom and someone saying popular girl was half flirting with me and trying to bully me to get me kicked out
Argument ensued female teacher kicks me out but says she's no longer wants to work with girls
Thank you
Biscuit word
Biscuit word. I'm supposed to say it in one go. Biscuit. Biscuit. Thank you for becoming a member. Biscuit
Please enjoy the emotes. I have new emotes on the way soon tm once emmy icers and
Mercies are done. And then I will send off azure shivys and my batch
Shivys emotes should be getting updated soon tm
What does that mean and when does when is it gonna happen?
When the concept artist when I send the files onto the concept artist that edit them for me
Hmm
Bake around for 15 minutes. I am not going outside at 1 a.m
Okay
As as much as I love to think that I'm strong and I'm safe and I'm this and I'm that
I'm no going outside in the dark at 1 a.m
The only time I've ever done that and the exception was for gimley
I'm sure I'm talking about you when you jump the fence, which I'm still not forgiving you for
And
but yes
Viva pinata was my first journey. She was it filled with fun
Viva pinata
Why not
because I'm a weak a weak tiny girl and
I have been taught not to go outside at dark and I'm gonna stick to it. I'm gonna stick to that advice
um
Yeah, gimley be a good girl. Please literally I love night walks. I would probably love them too
I'm not gonna go outside. I'm too scared
um
After class the girl sends two guys after me and absolutely destroy them and toss them down a small grass hill
But my supplements in my bag were ruined
What are you dreaming about refling? Then I was in a weird brazil city. Oh my god come to brazil
They walked across a crazy floating glass hundreds of platform things. Oh, that's like in china. There's like a glass platform bridge
And then I got to the bottom woke up. No idea what any of that meant
Anyway, I absolutely need to see your soup pick so I can praise your wife's skill
I like how it just ends. Anyway, show me the soup. I'm gonna make this soup. I'm so excited
Anyway, I'm proud of you trying to get healthy. Yes
Um, yes, I'm trying to be a lot better. I've been hydrating more. Um, I've not been eating takeaway
I've been good girl and not been ordering
um
Unhinge mo you guys are having insane dreams
I had a dream that someone handed me money in a red envelope and I was like, isn't this not what happens on that chinese tradition?
Where a red envelope is given you with money in size?
um
I don't know what it meant because I was like as much as I joke that a
my chinese auntie that runs the chinese but
I
We're not actually blood related. She's just really nice to me. You know, mm-hmm
Bro, turn to me. It's good game
Shibi time. Oh shibi up. Okay moment. I never realized. Thank you. I never realized
I never thanked you for reviving me environment. I'm sorry. No, don't cry. All right. Hold on. Let me make 100 sure
Doodly diddly that um record recording redirecting into shibu. Oh my god. She's doing a collab get ready
I've been looking and loving and thinking and dreaming
Birthday in real life super cat. Oh my god big stretch. All right, everyone stretch. Oh
That's right. Let it out
Stretch. Okay. We have stretched
Hi, johnny
Could you run through some pet names during one of your asmr streams? I have fantastic news for you
When I am recalibrating your mind temporarily. I don't do permanent hypno stuff. I don't like it
I don't like permanent stuff. It freaks me out. Um when I am attempting to recalibrate your name
So you forget your current name and you become a wreathling. I am going to be doing lots of praise
I'm going to be calling you my darling wreathling my perfect wreathling that this my that by death by death
Um, so I hope you're ready for the pet names that come in that stream
I'm definitely writing a lot into the script and I'm definitely going to extend the script
But I did a lot of the original hypnosis stream off the top of my head and I'm really fecking worried
That I'm going to run out and not know what to do because I kind of panic when I don't feel confident
off my back guys
No, don't don't pull your back out
I was kidding when I said you guys were og sons. Hold on a minute. You are og sons. I'm on to you
I'm on to you. You little you little og saners
I'm coming for you. I'm coming for your peck all
Uh, but yes, I'll do um
Uh
Ignore my last message about the roman girl. Please don't worry. I looked into it too and I was like shit
It's a layer of romulus. I was like shit
Shit, but we'll see we'll see wreathling. There's time. There's time wreathling. Please don't worry. We'll find out
I really don't want to compete with a tight
I say that as if I don't have a bunny girl, but I was different. She be was different, but I love she be
My back my back do be hurting call us a good boy and rubber chest and pair here and then we can be puppies together
I'm old but you're not old
I don't think I don't think there he's old. Am I going mental? I don't know. Maybe it's because like
um
No, I just I just didn't see it as old. I feel like when guys are older like that's
desirable
So it's not a bad thing
I'm not that old although. I am fast approaching the wrong side of 30
No, like that's the stop it the bail. I don't talk about yourself like that. No, I thought it was like
I thought it was good that a guy was older
I don't know
Maybe i'm being dumb and like because I did say that I was gonna put an ose on a dinosaur vtuber
So don't take everything I say like literally I have very low IQ
I have room temperature IQ I can admit it. So don't listen
I've really enjoyed your use of vtuber assets in the tavern stream. You enjoyed them
Yeah, oh g sons rejoice. I'm only 20 strong. He thinks I'm undesirable. No, I never said that. Oh my god
I'm gonna fart in your mouth. I never said that. I just said being older isn't bad
That doesn't mean I'm saying being younger is bad either
Stop it. Open your mouth. I'm farting in it
And inhale my methane gas
Homemade made it myself. It's organic. I assure you
Oh, can you taste the red onion I ate earlier?
I have three streams open right now. Wait, I see is I see me and sheepsters still up
Uh, Stranny, do you block people on marshmallow? You skipped mine yesterday after black ops?
Well, we think because I'm reading yours. I've not blocked you. I've not I've I genuinely have not blocked one singular person from marshmallow
I get no shit. No one brings any shit to my doorstep, which I'm obviously, you know, really happy about
Um, I have not blocked a single person
Um, and the brain worms are eating me alive. I might have said something to upset you. No, you don't upset me. Sorry
I'm probably more on the head. Yes. I
I don't want to be like, yes, you are in your own head
But please don't overthink stuff with me like I promise you
If we judged each other on our worst days, we would not be here right now and yet here we are
So let's not judge each other on our worst days. I won't judge you. You won't judge me deal
Yeah
Craig a guardsman
1114 thank you for the extended membership. I'm going to be here
I'm going to be 31 here in november law. I'm practically an old geezer. I don't know that is
I feel what would I call old?
Huh, I don't know what I would call old
Take away. No, don't don't don't don't don't try and get me to get take away
You can have marocans by the way brain worms are strong with this one. Yeah, how do you even block them more?
I don't know. They're anonymized so
I don't know
I'm look was it
There was three marshmallows have not read from hi strongy how much to lick your chair and then become your chair
Was it that riefling was that your one that I never read out loud?
Was it be honest? Was it the horn dog one?
God I went or was it this one god
I want to give you so much of my ink right now. How can you be so cute yet?
So damn sexy at the same time mommy riefling
brainworn riefling was that you
Was that or reflect was it this one?
Just need to stretch that starfish out enough to grab that cherry and it riefling brainworn rief. Was that you?
Hmm was that you with those ones that I never read out you?
Be honest
beyond
Was that that was you wasn't it bend over for a spanking you naughty boy
You naughty naughty boy
Um, don't worry strongy we can go on night walks together so you aren't scared
You just need to keep your collar on like a good pop. Oh, it's coming soon
It's coming soon. My collar is coming soon. I'm so f**king excited. My dog bull is going to take longer
I
Want dog bull man
But I have to wait I have to do collar
But I get collar and leash mama leash. Yeah
Maybe I'll do a cheeky photo on the alt clip
Naughty
I went back to your hypnosis ASMR due to a rough weekend. It was a wonderful experience the second time
It really felt like my attention was rocking as though I was on a boat
I was actually laying down it
It moving towards the guided visions of the sea and your glowing pearlescent eyes
Yeah, and the increasing darkness of the ocean was a joy each time I've indulged
I've come out of it full of optimism and energy like had a good night's sleep and I'm not sure why
Since I'm new to the whole hypno thing and I'm normally extremely protective of my brain because of decision-making
I don't know how often I can indulge keeping it in my back pocket though for extra hard times
Oh god. Thank you for trusting me with it as well. Like
I think you can definitely have like bad actors
No, I like don't get me wrong
You know if you like to indulge in it you do um
I just I'm so worried about the safety side of it. I get really nervous to do it
But uh, I I definitely have more confidence because of that stream
So hopefully I can do it justice in the stream two days away as well
Regardless, it's been great to support Mimi's and I appreciate it a lot. Thank you Johnny. Thank you
And indulge like vealers first generation adult exactly
I I wasn't even a joke that was just serious. That was just feedback. Good morning. It's Johnny. What color today if applicable? No color
I ain't wearing nothing
Well, I'm wearing the hoodie thing again. I just wear the same thing over and over
Maybe I just need to take a picture so you guys can imagine what like so you can see what I'm streaming like
I'm never wearing anything now
I like when you smile. It's the second best thing you can
Do with your lips
We playing
What's better than a rose on your organ? Oh shit. Hold on. What's better than a rose on your piano?
Two lips on your organ
Thank you. Thank you. You hear all this
Imagine a soup stream mummy cooking for us. I am so down to do cooking streams if you want. I have a bacon stream planned next
in
October
Before my don't know thon I'm gonna don't tell my gen mates. Okay. This is a secret between us reeflings
I'm gonna do a bacon stream where I bake like one item that I think the girl is and I'm gonna explain
Why I think through that and I'm gonna try and like draw them on the as well
Okay
Okay, so
Also, whoever fucking you know who you are that did that
You know that azura adorable like cross postboard whoever did the fucking cake spread meme? I am I'm gonna obliterate you
I don't know if Azura recognized it as the ass spread cake meme
But oh my god
Whoever did that, you know who you are and you're in trouble. That was foul
I don't think Azura knows what that reference is. You are foul. You naughty boy. You naughty boy
Well, that was that was so good though, but I was silly. I don't think she knew what it was
Did she know did she say what she knew what it was or no
You're smile. Yeah smiling because I don't think she knew what the meme was
The fun like I think she took a little like spread cake which makes sense to her
But I don't think she's seen that original. I think she's innocent
I don't know who you are, but I will faint you and I will peg you
I don't think she realized I recognized it instantly and I was like, uh
Uh
I did it speedrun that cake gospel. I'm also lost to be honest showable time right, okay
I'm going to redirect into shipper shipper tin
Strong in my beloved. Can you see extra virgin olive oil with a severe vocal fry?
Extra virgin, wait, what's a robot?
Here to pack this customer's order extra virgin olive oil
There you go
Oh
But yes, okay. Thank you so so much. I'm a redirect into shipper tin
I am going to do you have any plans for hypnosis content on patreon?
No, I don't because it's against patreon to us. Thank you for your comment
I will put it on my alternate twitter for free once I have an ability
I have time to edit it. Don't worry. It's coming soon to you. I'm strong a test marrow
This is from my marrow count to see if your blog knows. Okay. Thank you so much reasons for hanging out with me
I really enjoyed playing peggle with you even though we did finish the campaign mode
Which is exactly what I wanted to do but not the bonus one. I'm going to redirect into shuby. Please enjoy her club
I'm going to take five minutes and make a cup of tea and then I will put up valetro and ramble more
Okay, I will thank you for so much for coming if I I'm going to get distracted if I talk too much. Okay. I love you
Please enjoy shuby
Okay, please enjoy shuby
See in five minutes if you remember if not, I'll see you tomorrow and through a window
Bye